this week a lot of network shows are
returning to the air after a two-week
break because of winter olympics one of
those shows is NBC's this is us now
that's a very popular show that is a
this is us is a huge ratings hit and it
became clear to me I was thinking about
it because I like to think that one way
for a TV show to get huge ratings these
days clearly is to feature searing
family drama
so I was thinking over this little
hiatus we had why not add some of that
family drama
to our show smart right it gets millions
of people seriously people are going to
tune in this is bound to work so ladies
and gentlemen we start tonight let's do
it
there is nothing and I mean nothing more
important than family what do you know
about family
you hardly had any time for us because
you're up goofing around like a huge
phony with a bunch of Hollywood actors
you're doing string dances and grabbing
nipples while I'm stuck here cleaning up
after you how dare you this may look
like fun but I assure you every minute
of it is a living hell it's hard work
you try listening to some actor tell a
story about his family's vacation to
Boca Raton it's not easy I work I work
and I give and I am a father and a
husband and I care about you oh you care
do you well then why don't you do
something for me why don't you tell me
what your son's name is so what is it
he doesn't know he'll never know that's
why I gave up on him years ago and I
suggest you do the same
[Applause]
this can move this spring on tidiness
and you go
you
you